she like throws it at your forehead now
we're gonna put the sauce right today
we're gonna be waffling Taco Bell
what is your Taco Bell experience I've
only had it like late-night after
drinking it's good though if every time
I have it I'm like oh yeah this is good
stuff it's great they thought they have
really mastered the market on
combinations of cheese bread but
waffling is apparently I think the teens
are doing it I had no idea
let's waffle some tacos she's ready to
crunch it's definitely one of my
favorite items it is a hard shell
wrapped in the soft shell with meat and
cheese again it is just talking about
format I know I feel like I'm gonna have
really high expectations for Taco Bell
now after waffling everything say
honestly I think waffling just upgrades
food interesting yeah
let's waffle some ice cream I don't see
if you feel the same okay what does ice
cream go on Oh
I think she's ready
[Music]
honestly immediate boss this is an
improvement hell yeah oh wow they should
waffle everything they talked about this
is an improvement cuz it locks in all
the meat talk about stuff falls apart
because it's you know what you but this
like Sears it to where it can't fall out
yeah it's such a happy place
mmm like I feel like I would cut that
part off that's right and Jesse didn't
even cheese part so because of that I'm
gonna tell me this is Sam Stein Allen
Joanne
I'll give it a 4 - let's do it
we're gonna waffle a Crunchwrap supreme
do you have you ever had a criticism no
out of it there anything good is just
like a card for Tia wrapped in a
software tear again with meat cheese
lettuce tomato let's see what it's like
as a waffle let's hop that on there and
like that okay in the center I want that
pattern there we go
I wanted that she does go yeah yeah I
believe you know how to cook mm-hmm I
think that thing's supposed to turn
green when this is done but he's fine I
don't know if it's familiar with Taco
Bell items she sounds pasty Wow are you
dissing please it cuz it makes the edges
more crispy and I think it packs
everything in more because sometimes
think of all that's like this is very
bad
my thoughts are I rarely eat Taco Bell
in this is good out of five bills
how many bells for the others I would
eat this again filling it up for four
out of five yeah at least a 3.5
cheesy potato broiler yeah it's a nice
and heard shape other than color that's
the way it comes out is really advanced
for heating walk instead we miss Adriana
by phone and waffle and waffle and is
she ready no she's not oh yeah Taco Bell
baby potato girl is great it's got a
bacon cheese potatoes and then there's
like a sauce extra hot man talk about
potatoes are great it sounds like it's
boring but it tastes really good I was
ready to be disappointed
this is a griller they already flat
press it and Grill it and then we
basically just reshaped it
I mean don't put yourself down me yeah
we do a lot more than that thank you I
mean I really needed that today good
luck I knew we'd eaten a girl mm-hmm I'm
gonna pot Wow
out of everything we've had so far I
think no satisfying least impressed I
give it a 3.5
so next up we have the quesarito it is
like a burrito wrapped in a burrito
essentially there's meat on the inside
and there's a burrito with shredded
cheese in there and then on the outside
of that burrito
they put queso and that's why it's a que
Cerrito this is the K Cerrito on the row
we have flattened just to ability oh I
don't think this did well in the waffler
I don't think so either I think that's
all the queso from the outer show on the
it got pushed down that was high what we
heard screams okay I like this with the
chicken I don't think the waffling did
anything I think it would have been fine
how it was before and still would have
tasted the same cuz now I think it's
just mushy yeah I mean this might be my
least favorite thing so far yeah I would
give this a chew of it do you don't my
not to now now we're gonna make these
nacho fries we're gonna make them waffle
fries well they're still nachos hey my
son what shape should we do our
pentagram I mean this is close to Satan
as we're gonna get baby how do you do oh
wait it's a there's a star star inside
the inside the circle wait okay that's
not a that's a wheel this is my laughs
vinegar no just literally made a wheel
how is this any better it is better does
that look like a pentagram I've dabbled
in the occult no but looks like the
pentagram doesn't know it does it's
taking shape
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
Wow that [ __ ] agree and it'd turn out
pretty good so we got these nacho fries
what a pentagram
yeah she's jumbled now oh really I don't
think that the waffle iron did anything
to add or to take away from it you just
taste like crispy fries and make them
tell us good to me so I wouldn't give
them putting out though I thought they
improved muffled three point five we did
it Tibo awfully overall I think the food
items improved okay they were waffles
this also taught me I know a lot of Taco
Bell food we do I don't know what that
says about me
[Music]
you